an asteroid is headed straight toward
Earth initially scientists thought it
would miss us but they've made some
serious
miscalculations and now it's headed
right toward our giant Blue
Marble what happens
next does this mean the end of
humanity can we change the trajectory of
the
asteroid and why might this actually
happen by the year
2029 this is what if and here's what
would happen if an asteroid hits Earth
this
year now this sounds like a fun
hypothetical but an asteroid coming for
Earth it's no laughing matter it could
happen scientists had thought that
asteroid
99942 also known as apus might hit Earth
by the year
2029 a bofus was discovered in 2004 and
scientists have been closely monitoring
it ever since at one point research
suggested that the asteroid had a 2.7%
chance of hitting
Earth yeah scary I know but since then
new calculations predict that the
asteroid will whiz by Earth at a
distance of 30,000
kilm now considering that the Moon is
380,000 KM away this asteroid will be
incredibly close but at least it won't
be hitting us of course calculations can
be wrong let's say that in this case
they are and Aus is coming right toward
Earth way ahead of schedule the asteroid
is going to hit us this
year okay let's see what we're dealing
with apus is 3 40 m in diameter for
reference that's taller than the Eiffel
Tower but is it the worst asteroid Earth
has ever seen n lucky for us it's not
even close the chickaloo asteroid that
wiped out the dinosaurs was estimated to
be 10 to 15 km wide so now we're dealing
with chick's little brother so what does
that mean for us will humans go extinct
from this impact well more on that in a
bit but first let's look at whether we
have any chance of stopping this
asteroid ah sorry about that it's
another one of those spam calls that I
get constantly you get them too like to
the point where you don't even bother
answering your phone well luckily the
sponsor of today's video Aura can help
you with that did you know that data
Brokers are making a fortune selling
your information to robo callers and
spammers all in hopes of getting more
info from you like where you live well
Aura works for you submitting optout
requests on your behalf to data Brokers
that are exposing your information and
they work at finding the threats online
that you can't even see it's super easy
to set up you don't need any apps or
vpns or anything like that you get
everything with a single login at a
single price so you can either let
people continue to exploit you and
profit from your information online or
you can go to aura.com whataa if to
start your free 2-e
trial okay the first step would be
identifying the asteroid which we've
already done we know how big a pofus is
and that it's moving at about 30
km/s now it's about the defense measures
we could use there's a couple being
looked into right now one of them being
the kinetic impactor this involves
sending a spacecraft to collide with the
asteroid all in hopes of changing its
velocity and
trajectory NASA has run some successful
tests using this method so that's an
option next would be what's known as a
gravity tractor a large spacecraft would
fly next to the asteroid and over time
its gravitational pull would eventually
change the asteroids path laser ablation
is next on the list of options yeah
Special lasers could be used to vaporize
parts of the asteroid's surface this
wouldn't destroy the asteroid but it
could alter its direction as well as the
size and impact of it and last but
definitely not least is the final
nuclear option yeah that's right as a
final Resort we could nuke
Aus and with the asteroid's massive size
as well as the lack of time we have
before it hits us
this might be the only
option but don't be too quick to hit
that red button nuking an asteroid can
have some serious downsides it could
split the asteroid up causing it to
fragment then you'd have dozens more
minor asteroids and meteors coming
toward Earth making the impact even more
devastating yeah and these wouldn't just
be regular asteroids either because of
the nuke they'd be r
radioactive this would mean that
significant parts of the world would not
only be impacted with asteroids and
meteors but they'd also experience
radiation levels only seen during
nuclear
warfare so what's the best option here
well it's tough to decide let me think
about this for a second
H oh well it's too late
now we took too long deciding what to do
and now the apus will be here any second
brace
yourselves you wouldn't get a good look
at the asteroid impact and that's
because it landed somewhere in the
middle of the Pacific
Ocean this is the most probable spot an
asteroid would land considering the
earth's surface is mostly water so you
might not see the impact but you
definitely notice it once the asteroid
hit our planet it was would be as
devastating as several thousand nuclear
bombs going off just with a lot less
radiation it would make a crater at the
bottom of the ocean as big as a
kilometer wide and what would happen
next would be even more
devastating the massive impact would
create giant tsunamis that would rage
worldwide several hours after the
asteroid touches down cities along the
Pacific coast would feel laus's impact
the tsunamis would travel across the
Pacific Ocean at jetliner speeds places
in North and South America like
California Peru and Chile would face
towering waves due to the energy from
the asteroid it would likely cause waves
taller than 30 m waves as big as this
are responsible for one of the most
devastating tsunamis ever in 2004
southeast Asia experienced a tsunami
that generated waves over 30 m tall
killing over
230,000 people but instead of waves like
these reaching just a few countries this
would be a complete Global
catastrophy not only with the Americas
experience these tsunamis but so with
Japan Australia and the
Philippines these places would all be
devastated by the impact tsunamis like
these would likely destroy millions of
lives so that's what would happen if an
asteroid hit the ocean but what if it
made impact on
land well to start the impact crater
would be much more significant we know
that an asteroid's impact crater can be
anywhere from 10 to 20 times the size of
the asteroid itself and now there isn't
any water to soften the blow so the
diameter of the crater could be as large
as 7 km with a depth of over 1 km
depending on where it lands this
asteroid could be big enough to
devastate entire cities the initial
impact would send a massive shock wave
that spreads for hundreds of kilometers
this could destroy entire buildings and
seriously damage infrastructure it would
throw tons of dust and debris into the
atmosphere it could get so bad that it
could cause an impact winter this would
be caused by a dust cloud temporarily
blocking the sun causing crops and
vegetation to die out which creates even
more casualties something like this
could last weeks or months and be an
overall environmental
catastrophe this entire event during and
after could cause millions of people to
be killed depending on where the
asteroid
lands we can only hope that an asteroid
Collision like this would land as far
away from people as
possible but now for the good news if
Aus did somehow make an impact it
wouldn't cause a mass extinction like
the chielo asteroid did for the
Dinosaurs the event would be incredibly
traumatic and have lots of casualties
but Humanity as a whole would live to
see another
day okay now that we've survived
that what happens
afterward what does the future of
humanity look like well that sounds like
a story or another what
if